- Good morning, everyone.
And welcome to the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
Good morning.
Can I hear back from you?
Great.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Institute.
And I'm so pleased you've
joined us for our annual gender
conference.
Here at Radcliffe, we foster
pathbreaking, interdisciplinary
inquiry into complex
issues like the one
we will deal with today.
We do this by convening
and supporting
leading scholars,
practitioners, scientists,
and artists from across
Harvard and around the world.
And we are committed to sharing
their work with broad audiences
through events like today's, and
many more throughout the year.
Today, in addition
to this conference,
we have an exhibition by
renowned visual artist
and a current Radcliffe
Fellow, Bouchra Khalili,
on view at our
Johnson-Kulukundis Family
Gallery.
Bouchra's installation titled
Foreign Office examines Algiers
between 1962 and
1972 when the city
was a hub of revolutionary
liberation movements.
The exhibition will be open
through Saturday, April 21,
but I'm hoping that some of
you will take the opportunity
over the course of today,
perhaps during the lunch break,
to go and see the exhibition.
It's in Byerly Hall, which is
two buildings down on the left
after you exit Knafel.
Bouchra's exhibition
and today's conference
are all part of our
programming this year
and next around the
theme of citizenship.
We have one more event
planned in a few weeks
around this theme.
It's an evening that is entitled
Red Sox Nation: Exploring
Sports and Citizenship.
It will take place on Friday,
April 27 at 7:00 in this room.
And I think it should be a
fascinating and fun discussion
with speakers from the
Red Sox, as well as WBUR.
We will conclude this academic
year's public programming
with Radcliffe Day,
an annual event where
we present the Radcliffe
Medal to an individual who
has had a transformative
impact on our society.
This year on Friday,
May 25, we will
honor Hillary Rodham Clinton.
The day will open with a
panel discussion on the US
in the world today, moderated
by Professor Nicholas Burns
of the Harvard Kennedy School,
with foreign policy experts
David Ignatius,
Meghan O'Sullivan,
Anne-Marie Slaughter,
and Michele Flournoy.
Former Secretary of
State Madeleine Albright,
who herself received the
Radcliffe Medal in 2001,
will then offer a personal
tribute to Clinton
in the second half
of the program.
After that, Massachusetts
Attorney General Maura Healey
will engage Clinton in a
wide-ranging conversation.
Now we are already at
capacity for Radcliffe Day.
But I hope if you are not
included in that number
that you will join us
virtually by tuning in
to the live webcast that will be
available through our website.
And we really do
hope many people will
enjoy the day with us.
For more information, please
take one of our Radcliffe Day
postcards.
There are some in
the back of this room
and down on the
registration desk.
Now before I introduce
today's topic,
I'd like to extend my gratitude
to the many people, speakers
and organizers, who've
made this day possible.
We began last night with
a fabulous opening event,
Show and Tell: An
Evening About Citizenship
with Documentary Filmmakers.
And so I want to include
them in my thanks,
and also mention all the
people behind the scenes whose
hard work made today possible.
And that includes
Becky Wasserman,
who's the Executive Director
of Academic Ventures, Jessica
Viklund, Radcliffe's
Director of Events,
and their outstanding teams.
So let's give them
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks also to
Dan Carpenter, who
chaired the faculty organizing
committee for the conference,
as well as the committee
members, Professor Sarah
Bleich, Melani Cammett, Jane
Kamensky, Michele Lamont,
and Mark Tushnet.
Finally, I'm grateful to
the Institute's supporters,
many of whom are
here with us today.
Your generosity ensures that
we can continue to host events
like this one, and that we
can make them free and open
to the public.
Citizenship is one of
the defining and dividing
issues of our time,
and it means far more
than formal membership
in a nation state
or the possession of a passport.
Citizenship informs
participation
in the social,
economic, cultural,
and political
activities of a nation,
and it is a critical
component of belonging.
With more than 65 million people
displaced from their homes
and with nationalism on the
rise in many parts of the world,
citizenship has taken
on even greater salience
in our current moment.
That said, some might ask,
but why devote a conference
to citizenship and gender?
Radcliffe's thematic initiative,
exploring citizenship,
is timed in part to anticipate
the centennial of National
Women's Suffrage in
2020, since we thought
it was important to embed that
milestone within the larger
context of citizenship rights.
But even if at least
some American women
have enjoyed full political
franchise for almost a century,
the link between
gender and rights
and the rights and
obligations of citizenship
is hardly a settled issue.
Still today, gender has
an important bearing
on many aspects of citizenship
and belonging around the world.
Some of the most fundamental
citizenship rights
continue to be negotiated
and redrawn along gender
lines with real
impact on real people.
Many of us are aware of the
very limited political voting
rights afforded women in
countries like Saudi Arabia,
but it is notable that even in a
wealthy, institutionally strong
democracy like
Switzerland, women only
gained the right to vote
in federal elections
as recently as 1971.
And it wasn't until 1990 that
Switzerland's highest court
ordered the last holdout
canton to stop barring women
from voting on local issues.
Beyond voting rights,
women around the world
are far more likely than men
to earn their livelihoods
in domestic work, often
as migrant laborers,
and often without the benefit
of legal and social protections.
Moreover, according to the
United Nations, only about half
of married women worldwide can
freely make personal decisions
about their health
care, sexual relations,
and contraceptive use.
Even here in the United States,
certain basic legal rights
still reflect gender inequality
and traditional gender norms.
Not even a year ago,
the US Supreme Court
struck down sections of the
Immigration and Nationality Act
under which unmarried American
mothers and fathers living
abroad had to meet
different standards in order
for their children to acquire
US citizenship at birth.
Under the old law,
in certain instances,
a US citizen mother could
transmit citizenship
to her child, while a father
in the exact same situation
could not, and vice versa.
In a nearly unanimous decision--
those are rare-- the
Supreme Court ruled
that these disparate
requirements violated
the Fifth Amendment's
Equal Protection Clause.
The court urged Congress
to remedy the issue,
and in the interim, the
residency requirement
that had previously
applied to fathers
would apply to all parents.
Writing for the Court,
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
called the differentiation
between fathers and mothers
"stunningly anachronistic."
And she argued that it
reflected-- and I quote her--
"two once habitual but now
untenable assumptions."
One assumption
was that a husband
is the principal
figure in a household,
in charge of wife and children.
The second and related
notion was that outside
of a marriage--
and I quote her--
"an unwed mother is the
natural and sole guardian."
These stereotypes lead
to an intricate system
of gender differentiated
regulations
that played a critical role in
US citizenship and nationality
law until 2017.
I will share just one more brief
illustration of the interplay
between gender and citizenship.
As all of us have
experienced in our lives,
we frequently need personal
identification documents,
whether for employment,
for school enrollment,
for health care, for housing.
These IDs typically
indicate our gender,
and herein lies the problem.
For many transgender
people across this country,
the process of
updating and using IDs
can be fraught with challenges.
Potential difficulties
include denied
access to public
and private services
and the risk of verbal
harassment or even
physical violence.
And in states with
voter ID laws,
the lack of usable
identification
could deprive citizens
of their basic right
to participate in our democracy.
According to research by the
National Center for Transgender
Equality, as of 2015,
68% of transgender people
lack even one form of ID
with their preferred name
and gender.
Only 11% had their
preferred name and gender
on all of their IDs.
And correcting this is not just
a simple matter of heading down
to the motor vehicle registry.
In February, the American
Civil Liberties Union
filed suit, challenging
an Alabama law that
requires transgender
people to show proof
of gender-confirming surgery
before the state would
issue a driver's license
that reflects their identity.
Eight other states have similar
rules, according to the ACLU.
Not all transgender
people want or can
afford this type of surgery.
But more broadly, the ACLU
contends that a medical
procedure cannot be a
prerequisite for acquiring
a government-issued ID.
To complicate matters
further, Alabama
is one of 34 states in the
country that either requires
or requests voters to show
acceptable identification
at the polls.
This creates a very real risk
that transgendered individuals
who present incongruent IDs will
be denied their voting rights.
So I hope these
examples illustrate
that gender continues to
intersect with citizenship
in very tangible ways.
Before us today is a totally
complex, multifaceted topic,
so I am delighted that we have
such a distinguished lineup
of speakers to help deepen our
understanding of the issues
at hand, and to suggest, I hope,
some productive ways forward.
So thank you all for
being here today.
And I hope at the
end of the afternoon
when the conference
is over that you
will join us for a reception
next door in Fay House.
It is now my great pleasure
to introduce EJ Dionne, who
will moderate our first panel.
EJ is a distinguished
journalist and author,
a political commentator
whom you may recognize--
certainly will recognize
his voice from NPR and PBS--
and an op ed columnist
for The Washington Post.
Here at Harvard, EJ has been
the 2017-18 Bloomberg Visiting
Professor with appointments
in the Divinity School,
the Faculty of
Arts and Sciences,
and the Kennedy School.
He is also a senior fellow
in governance studies
at the Brookings
Institution and a professor
at Georgetown's McCourt
School of Public Policy.
I also should add that EJ is
a good friend of the Radcliffe
Institute.
Please join me in welcoming
EJ and our first panel
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Liz.
I appreciated that comment
on voice and not face.
There's an old line
that he was born
with a face made for radio.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I can't tell you what an
honor it is to be here,
and particularly to honor Liz
and her extraordinary work
here.
That is one of the
central reasons I am here.
And I think that the
nature of this panel
and this whole conversation
speaks to Liz's commitment
to gender justice in
the context of a broader
commitment to social
and political equality,
and to democratic values.
Liz is a democratic and
egalitarian feminist,
and I think so many
of us appreciate that.
I also, as a
lifelong Red Sox fan,
want to salute her for
this forthcoming panel.
In my lifetime, the
Red Sox are proof
that it is possible to rise
from the bottom to the top,
and that's from
oppression to victory,
which is the whole purpose
of the Radcliffe Institute.
So thank you.
Thank you very much.
I've got to say, I
also love the hashtag
for this event, #radwhobelongs.
You can read that
in so many ways.
I am honored also to be part
of this discussion with three
brilliant thinkers.
I'm just going to right off
the top introduce them briefly.
There are more detailed
bios in your programs
that do them justice.
I'll introduce them in the
order in which I understand
everybody is going to speak.
Kari Hong.
First, she is an
Assistant Professor
of Law at Boston
College Law School.
Martha Jones, the Society
of Black Alumni Presidential
Professor and Professor of
History at Johns Hopkins
University.
And Tali Mendelberg, John
Work Garrett Professor
of Politics and Director of
the Program on Inequality
at the Mamdouha S. Bobst--
how'd I do--
Center for Peace and Justice
at Princeton University.
The topic for this
panel is rights, duties,
and responsibilities.
And I'm going to keep my
opening remarks very brief.
I think it's
entirely appropriate
to begin a panel on citizenship
with a discussion of rights
and duties and
responsibilities, because these
are at the core of
what it means to be
a citizen in a liberal
democratic society.
As citizens, we're
granted certain freedoms,
but we also face
expectations about how
we are to engage with each other
and with our political system.
The first words in
the US constitution--
I love to do this.
What is the first word of the
Constitution of the United
States?
- We.
- Yes.
And we don't say we enough
anymore in this country.
The first words are
"We the people."
And they convey something
very important of who
we think of ourselves.
They speak of the
obligations we have
to each other and our nation.
Democracy fails when
citizens don't exercise
their duties and
responsibilities, including
voting and organizing.
And if I may say
so, this is a year
when I think it's
especially important
to think about our duties to
engage in those activities.
I want to raise at the
start the importance
of thinking about rights,
duties, and responsibilities
through many analytical lenses.
And I think the wonderful
thing about this panel
is that's exactly what
they will do today.
Our focus is on
gender, but I think
we also want to keep in mind
the dynamics of citizenship
and of gendered
citizenship, and how
they are affected
by race, class,
immigration status,
and a variety
of other social factors.
Class is a framework that
in many prosperous parts
of our society can be
uncomfortable approaching.
And yet it is clear that
socioeconomic status
and growing income
inequality are
powerful forces shaping the
contours of American society
and politics.
Class dynamics often interact
with gender dynamics.
The persistent gender
wage gap, for example,
means that many women find
themselves more economically
vulnerable than
their male peers,
and are thus barred from
fully equal participation,
not only because of
lingering sexism,
but also because of
the hidden and not so
hidden injuries of class.
I would note the teachers
strike in Oklahoma
as an example of this.
And it's worth
noting that about 75%
of the people in that
underpaid profession are women.
In the conversation this
morning, our panelists
will help us think
through what you could
call an intersectional analysis
that brings in race, class,
and other social determinants
to give us a fuller
understanding of what you might
call compounding privileges,
and also compounding lack
of privilege that influence
political access and power.
Martha Jones will speak from
a historical perspective
about race, gender, and
birthright citizenship.
Kari will provide an
overview of the asylum
process and its problems and
discuss some possible reforms,
focusing in particular on
the value asylum seekers
bring to our nation.
And finally, Tali
Mendelberg will
present her fascinating
research about gender dynamics
in public speech and
group decision making,
and its implications
for civic engagement.
I just want to tell
one story, and then I
will go on to the panel.
This and the last year, my
son was doing some organizing
at Connecticut.
And he was doing
the door knocking.
He was trying to organize
anti-Trump feeling
into political action.
By the end, he was
doing door knocking.
He was knocking on
doors a couple--
a weekend before the election.
Knocked on a gentleman's door.
Happened to be African
American, and I
think that's important to his
appreciation for the rights
of citizenship, as we'll see.
At one point in the
conversation my son asks him,
are you going to be
voting on Tuesday?
And the man looked at my
son very seriously and said,
it's our job.
And in many ways,
I think this panel
is about our job as
citizens, men and women
committed to equality
and democracy.
So I'm honored to
be here, honored
to introduce this discussion.
After the panelists
speak, I will
ask some initial questions, and
I will open it up very quickly
to this distinguished audience.
And with that, I bring on Kari.
Bless you all for
being here today.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I just realized I never
tested the PowerPoint.
Is it set?
- Things here operate perfectly.
- All right.
OK.
Wonderful.
Well, thank you all
for inviting me here.
Thank you all for being here.
It's just been an incredible--
it's an incredible honor to be
with this grouping of people
and have this
conversation today.
Now as an immigration professor
and as an immigration lawyer,
being relevant in the past
year has been very much
a mixed blessing.
After working with immigrant
clients for over 20 years,
I have found that ICE raids
and the current anti-immigrant
rhetoric to be nothing
short of an extended viewing
of the scene in Star Wars
III where the Army of Clones
turned against the Jedi and
killed them all off one by one.
I should say as a mother
of small children,
my current literary
references are
limited to Star Wars
movies, and PAW Patrol.
[LAUGHTER]
But that said, I
do run optimistic.
With that hope in place, I
wish to discuss asylum law
as the means by which people
acquire new citizenship,
but also contribute
to our existing
citizenship in this country.
And I'll be focusing on what is
wrong with our current policies
and looking for the future,
what can make it better?
Now since Trump's
election, asylum
has been a part of his
transformation of immigration
law.
In his first week
of office, everyone
knows that one of his
first executive orders
was the travel ban.
But in the same week, he also
issued two other executive
orders relating to his
wider immigration crackdown.
Starting in that first
week and continuing
until the very
present, Trump has
been attacking the procedural
protections asylum seekers have
and the character of
those who seek asylum.
Trump has been
remarkable, and I actually
agree he is a
genius in realizing
that rhetoric and
optics are as if not
more powerful than the
actual policy changes.
He has been effective in framing
asylum seekers and refugees
as terrorists,
burdens, and frauds.
Just this past week,
Trump announced his plans
to use the military force
to stop what he called--
which is false-- an impending
invasion of asylum seekers
who are barbarians,
ready to kill and rape
Americans at will.
But quietly, Attorney
General Sessions
is making dramatic
policy changes.
He is making it more
difficult for those
fleeing from Central America
to qualify for asylum.
And just this week, he
announced a new policy
to penalize
immigration judges who
do not close 700
cases each year,
a policy that privileges speed
over due process and fairness.
Now Trump is also using
other administrative remedies
to interfere with
substantive rights.
He's seeking to expand something
called expedited removal,
the authority by which one
immigration officer has
the power to deport
someone without a hearing
and without an appeal.
He is using detention
to weaponize misery,
to encourage people to give
up actual asylum claims
and deter others whose
lives are in danger
not to come to
the United States.
The most shocking example
of weaponizing detention
is the separation of 53
children from their parents
when their parents presented
themselves at the border asking
for asylum.
The ACLU has filed a lawsuit
to end this practice.
The Washington Post has
called this "gratuitous malice
towards children."
But the Department
of Homeland Security
defends this, saying it's
simply protecting children
from human traffickers,
a patently false claim.
Now all of these practices
are worthy of alarm,
and they're worthy of criticism.
But I want to highlight that the
Trump administration is doing
nothing new than how prior
administrations, including
and especially the Obama
administration, has done.
Even the most shocking
example of separating mothers
from their children
is only different
in degree, not in kind,
from the past 20 years.
So before continuing,
I wish to start
with definitions of procedural
overview of the asylum process.
Refugees are people who are
outside the United States
and ask either the United
Nations or an embassy
for protection from harm.
There is an extensive
two-year vetting process
before they are admitted
into the country.
When they arrive,
they are partnered
with religious or
community-based groups that
assist in their resettlement.
Since 1980, over
three million refugees
have been resettled
in our country,
and not a single one has
committed an act of terrorism.
Asylum, by contrast,
is protection
for people who are living
in the United States.
This is available to those who
are fleeing persecution, which
is legally defined as a
likelihood of harm or death
arising from political opinion,
religion, nationality, race,
or particular social group.
This applies to those
who arrive and have asked
at the border for
protection, but also this
is available for people who
are in the United States
on student visas, on tourist
visas if conditions change.
Either a coup happens
in their home country
or a personal
religious conversion
occurs so that they
are now in danger.
They can then apply
for asylum, even
though when they
left their country,
they were not in
danger at that time.
Now it's important to remember
that the actual number
of asylum seekers and
refugees is relatively small.
In 2017, 120,000
refugees were admitted
into the United States.
37,000 asylees or asylum
seekers were admitted.
Asylum seekers were
3% of all immigrants
who received any form of legal
status in the United States.
Combined, refugees and asylum
seekers are 13% of all those
who receive legal status.
So these are very small
numbers, so it's puzzling to me
why the systematic
campaign against them
has been occurring.
So with my remaining time, I
wish to highlight two points.
One, identify specific
ways that the laws
have failed and attacked asylum
seekers for the past 20 years,
and then second, identify
important reforms to pursue
both now and later once the
political power shifts away
from the Trump administration.
First starting in 1995,
the Clinton administration
took away the
automatic work permit
for those who were
seeking asylum.
This was justified as a
way to end asylum fraud,
but the instances of fraud
have never been substantiated.
Second, President
Clinton also favored
administrative
efficiency over accuracy.
He imposed a one-year
deadline by which
people had to apply for asylum.
At the time, the United Nations
criticized the United States
for adopting this
rule, but we've had it
for 20 years and counting.
For people then
who were otherwise
shown to face a likelihood
of harm or death
in their home country,
they are barred
from getting asylum if
they do not fill out
the right paperwork in time.
Third, in 1996, there's
a law called IIRIRA,
the Illegal Immigration Reform
and Immigrant Responsibility
Act, which created a rule so
that anyone who's denied asylum
in the United States, Canada,
or Mexico cannot apply
in a bordering country without
first returning to their own
country where they fear harm.
Fourth, expedited removal
was created in 1996
again under President Clinton.
And Obama has used this
with ruthless efficiency.
From 1996 until 2016,
5.5 million people
have been ordered deported.
But through expedited
removal and reinstatement,
another rapid removal
procedure, 4.2 million
have never had a hearing.
They have been turned away
by one immigration officer.
This means that
4.2 million people
have deported in the last
20 years without a hearing,
without a lawyer, and
without an appeal.
In the past 20 years,
76% of all deportations
have been done
without a hearing,
and expedited removal
accounts were half of this.
Expedited removal
allows for anyone
who appears at the
border who says
they are afraid that they
technically will have a right
to apply for asylum.
But if they do not claim a
fear, they are turned away.
Now this is supposed to
protect asylum seekers,
but in practice,
two recent reports
show that the error rate
is exceptionally high.
Mistakes are made both
accidentally and intentionally,
and there is no review or
appeal to correct them.
Examples of the mistakes
include a border patrol officer
denying a claim to
a Chinese Christian
because he did not go to church.
The border patrol
officer did not
know that Chinese Christians are
so repressed they do not have
a formal church they can go to.
Another asylum seeker was denied
because the officer did not
believe that Uzbekistan
was a real country.
And the officers who conduct
these interviews in Spanish
are not required to
be fluent in Spanish.
In a court hearing,
the court appointed
Spanish translator was unable
to understand the border patrol
officer when she was explaining
what she says to asylum seekers
to explain the legal
rights that they have.
Now there is an
extraordinary lawyer
named Stephen Manning,
who's developed
a database for volunteer
attorney corps to share files
at detention centers, which
has allowed numerous volunteer
attorneys to help represent
thousands of people.
In a study of 35,000
people, these lawyers
reversed and reduced
expedited order removals
at rates of 97% in one detention
center and 99% at the other.
This means that when
someone has a lawyer,
that expedited
removal is reversed.
Expedited removal then is
efficient and effective only
in turning away those who are
entitled to legal protection.
Now fifth, in 2005
under President Bush,
Congress passed the Real ID Act,
which makes any inconsistency
a basis to deny asylum.
This means if you're
fleeing for your life
and you use a false
name at the border
because you used a
false passport to escape
from your government,
an asylum officer
can deny your entire
request for asylum
because you lied to an officer.
Congress enacted this law to
overturn the practice used
by the Ninth Circuit to
only deny consistencies
that go to, quote, "the
heart of asylum claim."
So if you lied about
fleeing your country
for being a political
activist when in fact you're
not a political
activist, that is
a lie that goes to the
heart of the asylum claim.
Now substantively, the
Real ID Act makes no sense.
Attorney General Mukasey,
Attorney General Gonzales,
and even Attorney
General Sessions
have all been caught lying
to Congress while serving
as attorney general.
Now their first offense
was to ask for context
before being judged
about their lie,
and also whether there's
a legitimate reason
for the lying.
However, asylum seekers are
not afforded that privilege.
Now since the 1980s
on a given day,
there were 30 immigrants
that were in detention.
Today there are 400,000 at a
cost that begins at $2 billion
a year.
In response to the optics of
the Central American refugee
crisis when women
and children were
at our border in
large numbers, it
was President Obama
who used detention
to weaponize the
latest in deterrence.
He said in interviews and
sent Vice President Biden
to Central America
to tell people not
to come to the United States.
He chose to create
family detention centers
to try and discourage
those who arrived
to give up their claims.
He even went so far as
to apply for a daycare
license for these
detention centers,
putting up playground
equipment and jails,
saying that these
conditions of confinement
with no schools and
no normal childhood
serve the interests of children.
Obama was the one
who adopted a policy
that children as young
as four years old
have to represent themselves
in immigration court
without a lawyer.
This is a critical moment
to ask why we are doing this
and why we have been doing this.
This question is
particularly important,
because by government
numbers, 88% of everyone
who presents themselves
at the border
has a legitimate
claim for asylum.
So in so turning to
reforms, I believe rhetoric
is as important as policy.
My first proposal for reform is
to shift the framing of asylum
from policing fraud,
which does not exist,
to accommodating
reasonable fear.
If 90% of asylum seekers
have a chance of winning,
we should start resettling
them rather than
making it harder to give up
the relief that they are owed.
We need to hire
more asylum officers
and train them so they can
more quickly decide the cases
and have a lighter
workload to do that.
We need to repeal the one-year
bar to let documented fear,
not filing deadlines,
determine who gets relief.
And we need to return to the
heart of the asylum claim
standard to make sure that only
material inconsistencies can
deny claims.
Now second, the shift
is away from containing
people in detention to
supporting community
integration.
We need to end detention
for all asylum seekers.
We need to end family
detention centers.
And we need to end
expedited removal.
If the only way we can
deport 4.2 million people
is by taking away the
protections of a hearing,
a judge, and judicial
review, perhaps we
shouldn't be deporting
4.2 million people.
If this is unrealistic,
we have to start
by providing
lawyers to all those
who are subjected to
expedited removal.
And this is a process
that's already
been started in many
states and cities who
fund lawyers to represent
people who are detained.
And also, we finally just
need to treat asylum seekers
like we do refugees.
We need to greet them
with work permits.
We need to provide them with
English lessons in the way
that Canada does.
And we need to partner with
religious and community groups
to assist in their integration.
Now third, I think the most
important power of Trump
has been how effectively
he communicates rhetoric.
Policy changes are not enough.
We must counter this
persistent effort and campaign
to explain the value
that asylum seekers have
and the contributions they
make to the United States.
We all have fantasies, I
think, that if we were tested,
we would have chosen
the morally right path.
I think we believe that if we
had lived in Hitler's Germany,
we all would have
been first in line
to hide Anne Frank
and her family.
But I think watching how many
people have the actual bravery
or power to stand up to
Trump has been very humbling.
Trump said he only wants
merit-based immigration.
But do we really
want someone who's
been successful in North
Korea or successful in Putin's
Russia?
What have they done?
Who have they hurt
to succeed in systems
of corruption and persecution?
It is important to realize
that those who show up
poor at our borders are the
ones who have the bravery
to stand up to oppression
and corruption,
and did so at the cost of
their well-being and worldly
possessions.
The asylum seekers
are arriving heroes.
They are the ones who should
be getting the military parade,
not detention.
Now for all of us who
have immigrant members
in our family, we really do
understand the unique guardians
of American values that
asylum seekers have.
As a personal
anecdote, my father
was in World War II orphan.
He was adopted at age
five by my grandparents,
who were US citizens.
He went on and served in
the US military for 20 years
to show his gratitude
for our country.
Growing up, whenever
my siblings and I
engaged in political
discussions,
he was the first to say, we
are lucky to live in a country
where you can disagree
with the government.
He knew this.
He knew this firsthand,
because his biological father
was arrested by the
Soviets and sent to Siberia
for criticizing Stalin.
My father never saw his
biological father again.
My biological grandfather
lost his children
and he lost his freedom.
My father has explained
to me the value
of the First Amendment in a way
that a law school class never
has.
His ability to
transmit the gratitude
for the freedoms our country
has is something only
those who have lived in
countries without them
can truly appreciate.
The final piece then
we need to confront
Trump's policies of malice,
but also Obama and Clinton's
policies of callous
indifference,
is to continue the
public education efforts
on the invaluable
contributions that the poor
and the persecuted
provide to our country
so that there is a political
will to transform and reform
how we welcome asylum seekers
once the political power
returns.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I think everyone
in this room is--
whatever they
remember about today,
we're going to remember
the story of your father.
Thank you so much for that.
And-- yes.
And now Martha Jones.
Sorry.
I was so transfixed
by that story
that I forgot to
introduce Martha Jones.
- Thank you, EJ.
Good morning.
- Good morning.
- I also want to thank
the Radcliffe Institute,
and in particular Dan
Carpenter, for bringing us
together this morning.
Our discussion about
gender and citizenship
can proceed only with
a sense of urgency.
I think you've already
heard that this morning.
Perhaps you, like
me, are a witness
to a humanitarian crisis
here in the United States.
Our family, friends,
and neighbors
are being deemed
outsiders and criminals.
Their detention and
for many expulsion
is a testament to how
citizenship and specifically
birthright citizenship serves
as both a haven and a scythe.
The so-called accident
of birth wraps many of us
in an unassailable
cloak of belonging.
That same arbiter tears apart
families, exiles soldiers,
and brings about
raids in workplaces,
cutting a cruel line.
I'm a historian of citizenship,
drawn to this subject
by the early 19th
century struggles
of black Americans, many of
them the descendants of slaves.
Their struggles for a
formal, unassailable claim
to place to an indelible sort
of belonging, to the soil
as well as the body
politic is my subject.
I could not know when I
began this work a decade ago
that the early struggles
of African Americans
would resonate so strongly
through the circumstances
of today's black and
brown immigrants.
Thus, my remarks today
turn on a critical juncture
in the long history
of citizenship
in the United States.
The 14th Amendment's
constitutionalization
of jus soli or birthright
citizenship in 1868
is my subject, and
this is the same period
we heard Liz Cohen
speak about last night
when she referred to the
film Birth of a Nation.
And if that film offered
a parody of the Civil War
and Reconstruction
eras, I'll counter
with a history written
from the archives
rather than with lightning,
as director DW Griffith once
put it.
Birthright is the
primary regime to which
most residents of the United
States are subject until today.
Its advent marked, on the one
hand, a radical transformation
in what had been an ill-defined
regime of national belonging.
At the same time, it was
an incomplete revolution
or unfinished, to borrow
Eric Foner's framing.
It is a story for me
today in three parts.
Race, gender, and foreignness.
150 years ago, the US was at
work defining citizenship.
It was an effort to fix one
of the central oversights
of the nation's founding
constitution, which
had been silent on the subject.
Some argued that the framers
intended citizenship only
for white Americans.
Race was a prerequisite.
Black Americans, former
slaves and their descendants,
lived amidst ambiguity.
In the decade before
the Civil War,
they numbered nearly
500,000 or 1.6%
of the nation's population.
Most had lived in the US for
generations, building families,
schools, churches.
Their labor was an
engine of prosperity,
whether on rural farmlands
or urban cityscapes.
Still, free black Americans
lived under constant pressure
to leave the country.
So-called black laws
limited their travel, work,
and public gatherings.
Colonization societies
organized to send them
to Africa, the
Caribbean, or Canada.
In 1857, the Supreme Court ruled
in Dred Scott versus Sanford
that black people
were not citizens.
These forces all aimed to
remove African Americans
from the nation, whether
by coercion or force.
A lack of citizenship defined
a decades-long reign of terror
that reached into daily life.
If they were not citizens,
could black Americans
own homes and businesses?
Could they worship freely and
govern their own churches?
Could they control the
custody and education
of their children?
Could they travel to visit
family or secure jobs?
Could they use the courts
to protect their wages
or their personal safety?
No authority would say
for sure where they stood.
The answer came only
through a revolution.
Four years of civil war and the
near dissolution of the nation
brought about an end to
slavery and the enactment
of a new constitutional regime.
The adoption of the
14th Amendment in 1868
guaranteed citizenship
to those born in the US,
including former slaves.
Black Americans,
of course, would
face subsequent challenges
to their civil and political
rights, but after
the 14th Amendment,
they were ensured that
never again would they
face the threat of
arbitrary wholesale removal.
Gender.
Along with birthright
citizenship,
gender was first introduced
into the Constitution
with a 14th Amendment
provision that
aimed to guarantee black
men the right to vote.
The exclusion of women of
all races from the franchise
remained permissible.
Women, at least
those born in the US,
were now clearly citizens.
If this had long been assumed
in the case of white women,
for black women, this
was a new status.
What bundle of rights
might attend citizenship?
They were numerous, but when it
came to the elective franchise,
it appeared that women would
be guaranteed a lesser bundle.
No community was more
troubled by this turn
than that of radical
allies, abolitionists
and women's rights advocates.
Their conventions
were fraught over what
position to take on
the new constitution,
and factions emerged.
One view is best evoked by
Wendell Phillips' declaration
that this hour
belongs to the Negro.
This remark signaled
acquiescence
to a gendered political
order in which only men could
exercise formal authority.
Elizabeth Cady Stanton
captured the essence
of the competing faction when
she decried the possibility
that white women could be made
into the political inferiors
of black men who were,
quote, "unwashed and fresh
from the slave
plantations of the South."
Differences largely
framed as those
between white women and
African American men cut deep.
Black women might have been
at the rhetorical margins
of this debate, but
they were present.
And at least one, poet and
essayist Frances Ellen Watkins
Harper, intervened
to reframe it.
Her approach to the
question of rights
was as much intersectional
as it was universal.
The year was 1866,
and she declared,
"We are all bound up together in
one great bundle of humanity."
The nation, in
Harper's view, was
embarking on a grand
and glorious revolution,
and she argued that any
endeavor to transform
the standing of American
women required consideration
of society's weakest
and feeblest members,
alongside those individuals with
their hands across the helm.
In making her case, Harper
drew upon her vantage point
as a colored woman
who, she explained,
had felt every man's
hand against her
and hers against every man.
Harper cast herself as bound up
with the burdens of blackness
and the myriad injustices
that flowed from sex.
But if being an African American
woman in the mid 19th century
might have engendered
self-doubt, in Harper,
it fostered confidence
and conviction.
She was among an unprivileged
class of Americans,
yet held herself out as the
embodiment of the nation.
The most vexing challenges
of freedom, of citizenship,
and the Constitution
itself, she argued,
should respond to her call that
"We are all bound up together."
Foreignness.
If birthright guaranteed
that some were citizens,
we'd be mistaken to
think that the question
of national belonging
was settled.
A nagging vestige of the
pre-Civil War legal regime
was the Naturalization Act of
1790, which limited eligibility
for citizenship
or naturalization
to free white persons.
Black people were barred
from naturalization, even
after the 14th Amendment.
Some lawmakers proposed
striking white,
the word white from the act.
This met with
opposition from others
who feared that this change
would open the door not
to black naturalization,
but to the naturalization
of Chinese immigrants.
The revision's final language
extended naturalization
to those of African
descent, but no provision
regarding Chinese
immigrants was included.
And by 1882, the first of
the Chinese Exclusion Acts
closed this door tight.
What of the US-born children
of Chinese immigrants,
the descendants of
permanent aliens?
Were they citizens?
Perhaps not.
A view emerged in which it was
argued those born in the US
but exempted from domestic
law and regulation
were not citizens.
The argument went that Chinese
immigrants' indelible loyalty
to the emperor of China was
passed on to their children.
Such children were said
to be permanent aliens
like their parents.
When the case of the United
States versus Wong Kim Ark
reached the Supreme
Court in 1897,
it reflected the degree
to which thinking
about the 14th Amendment and
birthright remained contested.
Not only were highly influential
legal minds prepared to opine
that the US-born children of
Chinese immigrants were not
citizens, low-level officials
like Custom agents--
and I'm hearing Kari's
talk in mind today--
these low-level
officials at the border
in places like San Francisco
were the critical agents
in denying the re-entry of
US-born Chinese descended
people into the US.
Wong Kim Ark would go on
both to the US District Court
and then to the
US Supreme Court.
Only then would he
be granted his claim
as a citizen of
the United States.
Birthright citizenship
has a history
that extends across nearly
all of the 19th century,
and there are three
takeaways from
these early American contests
that I want to leave you with.
First is that citizenship,
even its formal parameters,
have shifted across time.
Citizenship has always
been a contested category,
a site for battles
over resources
and power, sometimes
taken up by those
who aim to expand its
parameters, but also by those--
such as those who
excluded Wong Kim Ark,
taken up by those
who would use it
as an instrument of exclusion.
And it's likely to remain so.
There was a question asked last
night about the rule of law,
and my answer this morning
is that the rule of law, when
it comes to
citizenship, has always
been a moving target and
a point of disagreement.
And our own moment
is no exception.
The second point is that
some 19th century Americans,
like Frances Ellen
Watkins Harper,
understood keenly the limits of
citizenship for framing rights.
She offered instead what today--
I think what we would
term human rights.
When she situated herself
and other black women
as bellwethers for the nation,
she challenged the premise
that any constitution, even
one radically transformed,
can wholly meet our human needs.
And our strategies
today will benefit
from thinking beyond the
domestic to the global
and to the human.
Certainly, this history
is a cautionary tale,
one that instructs us about
how the state can fail
to recognize, account for,
and incorporate communities
in our very midst.
There is much to
admire in the work
of the Reconstruction-era
lawmakers, their adoption
of the 14th Amendment.
But today, their definition
of what makes an American
falls short of addressing
our citizenship crisis.
For today's
unauthorized immigrants,
the 14th Amendment
provides no relief.
The once radical promise
of birthright citizenship
is beyond their reach.
Their lives tell
part of the story.
The Pew Research
Center estimated
in 2015 that 11 million
unauthorized immigrants--
3.4% of the overall population--
lived in the US.
They have built families,
homes, and businesses
across generations.
Their labors drive
economic growth.
They are integral to the
country in which they live.
And still, they have no access
to the rights of citizens.
They have no unassailable
claim to place.
2017 began with anti-immigrant
threats of mass deportation.
What followed has been
more quotidian, but no less
harrowing.
With no path to citizenship,
the 14th Amendment instead
becomes a generational scythe.
Families of mixed
status confront
dislocation and separation
as birthright slices
through households, severing
cross-generational ties.
It is a haunted
existence that produces
lives subject to the arbitrary
winds of political policy.
A new reign of
terror is underway.
As it was in 1868, people living
in the United States today
face schemes that aim
to forcibly excise them
from the nation.
The resulting crisis
exposes the Constitution's
unintended but tragic
limits, and calls
out for solutions as
bold and as imaginative
as the 14th Amendment once was.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much.
And now Tali Mendelberg.
- So thank you very much, Dean
Cohen and Professor Carpenter
and EJ for inviting me here.
And thank you all for
coming to this very
important and informative forum.
This is a wonderful conference.
I don't often have
the opportunity
to participate both in
scholarly discussion
and activism and the
arts all at once,
so really, a rare opportunity.
Wonderful.
My remarks are
based on a project
that I have been working on
to understand women's silence.
And as we all have seen
in this Me Too moment,
it is all the more urgent
that women speak up.
Unless women feel and
are in fact empowered
to speak their minds
and to articulate
their distinctive
perspectives, our society
can never achieve its
democratic aspirations.
So our personal inspiration
for this project--
and when I say our,
I mean my co-author,
Chris Karpowitz and myself--
our inspiration is
Madeleine Albright
who broke the glass ceiling
of American diplomacy
and national security and
wrote in her autobiography what
is essentially the
motto for our project.
And she wrote as follows.
"Early in my career, I
went to numerous meetings
where I was the
only woman present.
I would want to contribute
to the conversation,
but I would think, if
I say that, everyone
will think it's really stupid.
And then a man would say
exactly the same thing,
and the participants would
find it utterly brilliant."
And to this day, she
wrote, "I sometimes feel
a squirm of anxiety when
I interrupt a discussion
in a room with only men."
So the question for us
is, how is it that a woman
as tough and as talented
enough to become
the first female secretary
of state of the United States
find herself tongue-tied?
And not just when
she initially started
attending these
high-level meetings,
but afterwards too, continually.
And we think that
the reason that she
finds this twinge of anxiety
repeatedly is the same reason
that Cecile Richards, a woman
also tough and talented enough
to lead Planned Parenthood, was
cut off 44 times when she spoke
at a congressional hearing.
This was not a simple
case of partisan politics.
When a political scientist
named Laura [INAUDIBLE] examined
Senate confirmation hearings
systematically over many years,
she found that
senators at the time--
all-male senators--
systematically
interrupt and challenge
the testimony of women
much more than that of men.
And the key is,
they did that even
for the women who shared
their own political ideology.
Public speech remains an act
of highly gendered authority.
Women who break the glass
ceiling with their bodies
still have to figure out
how to exercise authority
with their voices.
It is no coincidence
that Albright had trouble
as the lone woman in the room.
Just about any woman who has sat
through a mostly male meeting
has had a similar experience.
Even informally
open meetings where
access is given to
all on the surface,
women tend to hang back.
Frank Bryan, another political
scientist and an enthusiast
of the New England
Town Meeting, spent
decades lovingly cataloging more
than 1,000 of these meetings.
And he found that women talked
about half as much as men.
Most of the men
at these meetings
spoke, and most of
the women did not.
All this should deeply,
deeply disconcert
those who rejoice when
paltry numbers of women
rise to power, whether
it is in government
or in corporate boards
where there's recently
been much discussion about
the small numbers of women
and whether that enables
behavior such as this coming
to light now with the Me Too
movement, or at the workplace.
In spite of all the progress
that one might point to,
gender role
expectations are still
deeply, deeply internalized
by women as well as men.
To be a good man is
to exercise authority.
To be a good woman is
to follow authority.
When women assert authority,
particularly over men,
they cross that fundamental
gender boundary.
So my co-author and
I wanted to know,
what could be done to actually
alleviate this problem?
So we carried out an experiment.
We recruited about
500 men and women,
and then we randomly
assembled them
into five-member
discussion groups.
And we charged these groups
with discussing and deciding
how society should
distribute income.
To ensure that they took
this task seriously,
we told the groups
that they would
experience the consequences
of their decision firsthand.
They would perform a
task to earn money,
and their take-home
pay from the experiment
would then be
adjusted by the tax
that their group actually set.
And the tax would
go to support those
who earned the least, in the
experiment and hypothetically
in society at large.
So this allowed us
to study how women
voice their perspectives
about poverty,
their perspectives
about income inequality,
and their perspectives about
the needs of women and children
who are disproportionately
affected
by poverty and by wealth
and income inequality.
We expected that groups
that had more women
would be more respectful
of women's contributions
to the discussion.
We thought these groups would
allow more time for women
to speak.
We thought they would
allow women to raise
their distinctive perspectives.
And we thought that women
would be interrupted negatively
far less.
In short, we thought these
groups would treat women,
see women as
influential contributors
to the group's decision.
These hypotheses will sound
familiar to those of you who
have been exposed to the
pathbreaking theory of Rosabeth
Moss Kanter, who found
in her pioneering work
that where women are a
small proportion of a group
or of an organization,
they are marginalized.
They are disempowered.
They are negatively stereotyped.
They suffered discrimination
and even harassment by men.
So all of this discussion
about sexual harassment
in the workplace would come
as absolutely no surprise
to followers of Kanter's theory,
especially where women are not
a majority of the group, are not
a majority of the organization.
But the theory is that
where women's numbers exceed
a critical mass, these ill
effects would all diminish.
We should be seeing
less sexual harassment
in workplaces where women
have the power of numbers
to set the tone, to set
the norms of behavior,
and to receive equal respect.
So critical mass theory has
been extremely influential,
and for good reason.
Organizations such as the
United Nations have actually
declared-- and I quote from a
United Nations declaration--
"The figure of 30% forms
the so-called critical mass
believed to be
necessary for women
to make a visible impact
on the style and content
of political decision making."
Since then, since
this UN declaration,
over 100 countries have
endorsed this goal.
Norway, for example, has
actually legislated quotas
on its corporate
boards, publicly traded
corporate boards.
They have set a 40%
minimum quota, a hard quota
by law, for these
boards to meet.
So this all sounds
terrific, and there's
only one problem with it,
which is that it doesn't work.
[LAUGHTER]
At least it doesn't
work consistently,
and it certainly does not
work at the 30% critical mass.
Norwegian quotas
have not noticeably
increased women's influence
on corporate boards,
although the
verdict is still out
since the introduction
of those quotas
coincided with the onset
of the great recession.
But research in other countries
in a variety of situations
looking at various government
entities, committees, and so on
finds at best mixed support
for critical mass theory.
So in our experiment, we found
that critical mass can matter,
but it depends.
What is needed is a much
larger critical mass
than scholars and
organizations have assumed.
And when you really
think about it,
this makes sense,
because 30% or even 40%
still leaves women in a distinct
minority of those present.
Group decisions moreover
are made by majority rule,
and majority rule means not only
that the majority preference
will win, but it also means
that the majority identity
category, the majority identity
group in that situation will
set the tone, will set the
norms, and will determine,
who is it who gets respect?
Who is it who is going
to be listened to?
So we thought the majority
identity in the room
is going to be crucial.
And we thought that assigning
a group to use majority rule
is going to empower women
when they are the majority
identity in the situation,
in the decision making group.
And our findings, in fact,
bear out this hypothesis.
We are randomly instructed our
groups to use majority rule.
When women comprised a super
majority of those present,
when they comprised 80% of
the members of the group,
the average woman
and the average man
were indistinguishable.
They were indistinguishable
in how long they talked,
whether they were later rated
by other members as influential,
and how often they expressed
their authentic views, which
we had assessed ahead of time.
This was not true for
groups in which women were
a minority of those present.
And we also found
that women suffered
fewer negative interruptions
from men specifically.
Remember back to our discussion
of the congressional hearings.
Those negative
interruptions really matter,
and they're correlated
with women's status.
Well, in these
empowered groups where
women had 80% of
the members, they
suffered far fewer of these
negative interruptions.
And they also talked
less about topics
that tend to be of
distinctive concern
to men, topics
about how to reduce
taxes, topics about finance.
They talked a lot more
about the needs of families,
and they talked a lot more
about the needs of children.
This is not a surprise
given that women are still
expected to fulfill
these nurturing roles,
and they are still expected to
be the ones primarily in charge
of taking care of children
and nurturing people in need.
So in these groups,
women advocated
for more generous distribution
to people living under poverty.
Now a variety of
research has shown
that women are, in
fact, more likely
than men to prioritize
alleviating poverty,
prioritize taking care
of children, people who
are vulnerable, prioritize
giving more generous assistance
to the poor.
And in that sense, increased
talk about those issues
represents an increased focus on
women's distinctive priorities.
Groups with female
supermajorities
were also more
likely than groups
with very few women, these
Madeleine Albright groups--
to enact these views into
their actual set policies.
They voted to set a minimum
guaranteed income for those
in poverty that was
half again as generous
as the minimum guaranteed income
set by groups with few women.
Our groups were a very
diverse mix of men and women.
They were a variety of ages.
There were a variety
of social backgrounds
and a variety of
political perspectives.
We recruited groups in a very
conservative community, a very
religious community, and
in a very liberal, secular
community.
And we found that these gendered
patterns were very similar
across these diverse communities
and diverse individuals.
Now by contrast where
women composed only 20%--
these are the Madeleine
Albright groups--
the same percentage
that's common,
not just in many meetings
but also on city councils,
also in the US House, also
in the US Senate, women
spoke traumatically less often.
They raised far fewer
times the concerns
that are distinctive to women.
They talked far less about the
needs of women and children
in poverty.
They were interrupted by
men at a far higher rate,
and they were less
likely at the end
to be identified by
the other members
as the most influential
member of the group.
These same groups also set
a very low poverty line.
They set a very low
minimum guaranteed income
that resembled the actual
low guaranteed minimum income
that our policies,
in fact, provide.
So our groups
simulate what might
happen if women's presence
on corporate boards
or in legislatures or
other places of power
were dramatically greater.
But in reality, of
course, the road
to female empowerment,
the female majority,
supermajority is going to
be very long and extremely
painfully slow.
The institutions that
most need these reforms
are the ones that are
least likely to convert
from a supermajority of men
to a supermajority of women.
So another possibility is to
replace majority rule, which
creates these very
negative dynamics for women
in the minority, with
unanimous or consensus rule.
Of course, we have
settings that already
use consensus rule formally
like the American jury system.
But to paraphrase Oscar
Wilde, "unanimous rule
takes up too many evenings."
[LAUGHTER]
But before I go to
what actually can
be done about unanimous
rule without taking
"up too many evenings,"
let me just tell
you what happened
with our groups
when we randomly assigned
them to use unanimous rule.
We thought this would create
an inclusive and respectful
conversational norms
that would invite women
into the discussion
and empower them.
And indeed, we found that under
this unanimous rule situation,
women did not fare
quite as well as they
did in the supermajority
condition with majority rule,
but they did much better than
these Madeleine Albright groups
did under majority rule, right?
So forcing the group to
use a consensus process
did, in fact, considerably
close the gender gap.
Women received far fewer
negative interruptions.
They were able to move that
minimum guaranteed income
up quite a bit.
But there is a
wrinkle, and that is
that where women were a
majority of the group,
unanimous rule
actually backfired.
So the irony is
that the groups most
likely to adopt a consensus
process in the real world
tend to be groups that
are predominantly female.
And we found that when we
analyzed race dialogue groups
that were studied by the
scholar Kathy Cramer Walsh
in the Midwest.
These groups attracted
predominantly women.
They had very explicit rules
that promoted a consensus
discussion process.
But when we looked at how often
women spoke and what they said,
we found these same
negative patterns
that we found in our
discussion groups.
So what we recommend
then is fitting the rule,
fitting the conversational
norm to the numbers
of women in the group, where
women make up a large majority.
Then the desirable rule
for gender equality
is not a consensus
process, but a majority
rule that empowers
women to actually set
the conversational
norm in the group.
However, when women
are a small minority,
as they are in many of
these discussion settings--
in corporate
boards, governments,
in the workplaces--
when we have the Madeleine
Albright situation,
we should encourage groups
to use a consensus process.
Well, what does that
really look like?
If we don't want to take
"up too many evenings,"
what does that really
mean in practice?
Well, what we
recommend is adopting
the kinds of
conversational norms
that our unanimous
rule groups did.
Give each person a set,
designated amount of flow time.
Allow each person to join
the conversation by default.
Don't leave it up to
individuals to decide
when to merge into that
fast-going highway,
just like Madeleine
Albright was talking about.
It's a huge barrier
for women in particular
to try to figure out when
to join that conversation.
And set a conversational
norm of equal respect.
Do not allow people to
negatively interrupt.
All of these gender-free
rules on the surface
end up having a vastly
disproportionate impact
on women in the group.
So thank you very much,
and I look forward
to the conversation.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much.
I realize that I may play the
Madeleine Albright role here,
and so I'm going to
ask all my questions
with a twinge of anxiety.
[LAUGH]
Thank you.
I always like to think
of what the Fox News
headline on an event will be.
And Kari gave it to us.
Trump declared genius
at Radcliffe conference.
[LAUGHTER]
So you could explain
that if you want.
I have a lot of
questions, and I want
to have a chance to
go to the audience.
- Fake news.
[LAUGHTER]
- I want to have a chance
to go to the audience.
Maybe I could ask
all of my questions
as background, because
if I read that right,
does that mean we only
have nine minutes left?
- Just for you.
- Oh, just for me.
Oh, OK.
Good.
All right.
Then I'll see you.
You should time these
things, as you suggest.
What I might do is package
the three questions
that I have for each of you.
And then if I can, I
wanted to get to one more.
So then I'll ask Kari, and
then Martha, and then Tali.
That's unfair to
Kari, because she will
have no time to think about it.
They will.
But you'll forgive that, I hope.
You get to go first.
Two questions.
One, just a factual matter which
is, did the Obama policy become
less aggressive over the
period of the administration?
Or was it-- my understanding
is there was a shift.
I'm just curious.
And what I also just wanted
you to talk about a bit
is how immigrants,
refugees, and asylum seekers
tend to get conflated in
the public discussion,
and how that can be a real
problem in talking about this.
And if you could talk about
how we think about that.
For Martha, I was so
struck by your comments
on the post-Civil war,
post-Reconstruction period.
And I guess I want to
ask both a specific
and a general
question, which is,
how we cast one
group's suffering
against another group's
suffering over and over again
in our history, and how we check
the rise of political equality
by emphasizing the claims
of one excluded group
over those of another
excluded group,
I'd just like you
to talk about that.
And then more concretely,
we need a solution
as bold as the 14th Amendment.
Now you could go on,
I think, for a while
about what that means.
But I would love you to
give us a taste of this.
And for Tali, a small factual
question and then a larger
question.
The small one is,
what evidence is there
that the forces
you are describing
about gender in a given
meeting or a given conversation
are also present by race or
class or immigration status?
In other words, how
much does the presence
of a group in certain
numbers affect it?
Or is it different with gender?
And then the larger
question-- and I'm
going to ask you this question,
because I want somebody
to talk about it.
You also wrote a great book that
won a big APSA award, The Race
Card.
And your comments today about
how women's voices are often
not raised or
interrupted or not heard,
I can't resist asking you to
talk about the 2016 election.
And what does your
research tell us
about the way Hillary
Clinton was or was not
heard during that campaign?
I'm sticking a rather
large question at you,
but I don't think you
will mind taking that on.
So let's start with
Kari, Martha, and Tali.
Sure.
So in terms of the
question of, was Obama--
did he ever kind of abate his
aggression towards immigrants?
And it depends on
what your metric is.
I mean, the expedited
removal started in 1996.
And at the time, it was supposed
to be just at the border
where people, if they
had just been crossing,
this used to kind of justify
turning people away who had
no ties or no right to be here.
In 2002, Bush extended to
the border to 100 miles
from any border, which includes
Boston, which basically
includes 2/3 of the
country because it
is the southern border, it
is the California coast,
it is the northern
border, it is in Chicago.
It's any waterway within
100 miles of that border
is where people
are now subjected
to these expedited
removal rules.
In 2014, that's when Obama
had the peak of the detention
and the peak of communicating
directly with people in Central
America, giving the
same message to them
in the radios and the
television that Trump
is doing through
tweets by saying,
don't come to our country.
You are not welcome here.
But Obama-- 5.5 million people
were deported in 20 years.
Three million were
deported by Obama.
And 76% of those were
without hearings.
So he persisted-- in
2015, he continued
with trying to get daycare
licenses for these family
detention centers.
It was a court that actually
rescinded that policy.
He did not.
And he went to court,
and he defended,
and he fought, and he won
in preventing children
from having rights to counsel.
So that was an ongoing
policy that he continued
to pursue until the end.
- Thank you.
Martha?
I think another way of
putting your first question
would be to ask about how it
is that we came to see the body
politic voting and
political culture
as a zero-sum game
in a democracy.
And this example from
the mid-19th century
of the debates between and
among former abolitionists
and women's rights advocates
is one that I think comes to us
and functions oftentimes more
so as a myth than as history.
And so I think that's one of
my intended interventions.
It's to say that when I
introduce a figure like Frances
Ellen Watkins Harper
in this discussion,
it's a reminder that the
body politic in 1868--
certainly in 2018-- could never
be reduced to African American
men's interests versus the
interests of white women.
That wasn't true 150 years ago.
That wasn't true in 2008, and
it certainly isn't true today.
So I guess I'm concurring in
part with Kari's point, which
is, there is a power
to storytelling,
to myth production.
And part of my work, of
course, is to try and meet that
with some history that
disrupts that, and reminds us
that the kind of thorny,
complicated textured questions
around citizenship, around
political rights that we
grapple with today
are old questions.
And they were as thorny and as
troubled as they were before.
On the question of
the 14th Amendment,
five years ago if we had
convened this meeting,
I would have been
much more circumspect.
I might have even been
mum on the question
of the 14th Amendment and
its birthright provision.
It's to say that five
years ago, law professors,
we were debating this question.
There were some
who were advocating
the repeal of the 14th Amendment
and its birthright provision,
advocating in the
alternative for a kind
of affirmative affirmation,
oath-based system
for citizenship in
the United States.
I was among those who was
reluctant, because in a sense,
I didn't want to let
the cat out of the bag.
I didn't want to
let, if you will,
the opposition
know that there was
this thing called
birthright citizenship
in the Constitution.
And that it is--
while robust in that the
amendment of the Constitution
is a complex process, that it
is vulnerable to amendment,
to rethinking.
Well, today that cat is
out of the bag, I think.
And part of my point today is to
urge us to seize that question
and not leave it to those
who would undo birthright
for the purposes of exclusion.
Those of us who advocate
for thinking and rethinking
about citizenship as an
instrument of inclusion
also have to think
critically about
birthright and strategize
about how we want to redo that.
So there were those who have
advocated repeal, replacement
with a kind of
affirmation system, others
who have proposed
folding in service
such as military service
as a door to citizenship.
I had been thinking a lot about
family and the ways in which--
I'm not going to say
family values, right?
Because that's not the phrasing
or the connotation I intend.
But the value of family, the
centrality of our expanding
and changing notions
of family is still
a core that might be
drawn more closely
to constitutional thinking
about, who is a citizen,
and why?
- And you might create
left-right coalitions.
[LAUGH]
I actually want to get
to that at some point,
but thank you for that comment.
So I've thrown a big
one at you, Tali,
because I knew you had
good ideas about it.
- Flattery will
get you everywhere.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm happy to talk
about that as well.
So let me take the
first question first.
Do we have evidence that a
similar dynamic to what I've
identified for gender also
exists for race, class,
immigration status?
And I would expand the question
to other types of identities
as well.
And the unfortunate answer
is that we have very, very
little research
on this question,
and we desperately
need that research.
So if there are any enterprising
scholars in the room,
I hope that you will put that at
the top of your priority list.
And it is something that I'm
thinking about how to study.
Want I would suspect,
what we do know
is that members of
identity groups with lower
levels of authority in society
do have greater difficulty
in merging into that
highway of the conversation.
Just as Madeleine
Albright indicated,
these marginalized
identities unfortunately
do carry not just
a social stigma,
but they carry a specific
deficit of authority.
And that means both
it's difficult to join
the conversation, and that when
one does join the conversation,
one tends to experience
a lesser respect
and experiences oneself as
less valued as an individual,
experiences one's
perspective and one's
very selfhood as less valued.
And we do have
qualitative studies
that point to that effect.
We have powerful
testimonies by people
who point to that effect.
I would just add just a
little bit of evidence
from research that I conducted
with a former graduate
student of mine,
Matt Tokeshi, who
is now a professor at Williams.
We did a systematic
study of whether
African American candidates for
high-level office such a Senate
or governor are able to talk
about race in the same way
that an identical
white candidate might
talk about race.
And we found that unfortunately,
the answer is far from yes.
A white candidate has
much more latitude
to say, to talk about
racial discrimination
and to point to
racial inequalities,
to point out when their
opponent in Trump style
has played the race
card against them.
And by contrast, an
African American candidate
who's identical--
these are experiments,
so we keep
everything identical
about the candidates
except for their race.
An African American candidate
has far less leeway,
and often tends to incur
harmful consequences,
and loses electoral
support from white voters.
So just a little bit
of evidence suggesting
that we should probably
expect, unfortunately,
a similar dynamic
when it comes to race
and probably immigration status.
Any kind of identity
that unfortunately
experiences a gap in authority.
As to 2016, I believe that
Trump represented a singularity.
That's not to say that
there won't be imitators,
but that his instance,
his candidacy
represented a sharp break
with other past practices
of campaigning.
And I think that he
benefited in that respect
a great deal from being
a television reality show
personality.
And a lot of the ways that
voters read him, the way they
interpreted him and
what he represented
was colored through that lens
of TV reality, reality shows.
So I think that in that sense,
there's a little bit of hope
there, except that his
incredible success might now
be imitated by others.
So in my book, The
Race Card, I pointed
to the importance of
conversational norms
of equality.
And I documented how,
over the past few decades
since the 1950s,
there has been a rise
in a very important
and very consequential
norm that prohibited
people from sounding
as if they were racist.
And that norm represented
a great deal of progress.
Trump clearly violated that norm
without very much consequence,
almost with impunity.
And so in that sense, I
think he really represented
a sharp break from the past.
All of that created a
perfect storm for someone
like Hillary Clinton,
who on top of that
probably experienced the adverse
consequences of lingering
outright sexism on
top of all of that.
- Thank you so much.
That was a great and
comprehensive answer.
I appreciate that.
A lot of people are going
to go away with that.
It is time for questions.
There-- is it one mic in
the middle of the room?
Is that the one I see?
Please feel free to come up.
While people are gathering,
I'm going to give you
a background question.
Don't answer it now, but if
you could bear it in mind.
I'd be just fascinated
if you have any thoughts.
Well, there's somebody
already at the mic, so
why don't you start?
I'll get to my background
question again.
Please identify yourselves
when you ask a question.
As a friend of
mine likes to say,
if you could have
a question mark
at the end of the sentence.
[LAUGHTER]
- Yes.
I'm Peggy Weisenberg, a devotee
of the Radcliffe Institute.
I for many years worked as the
lawyer for birth registration
in Massachusetts.
And I wanted to follow up on EJ
Dionne's dialogue with Martha
about what bold ways might
you be advocating for.
I don't see Jacqueline
Bhabha here.
She has a joint appointment
with the law and Kennedy School,
and hosted a conference
about birthright citizenship.
And there I learned--
I mean, there's a concern
about statelessness,
and the UN really wants to have
birth registration systems.
And some countries
don't use either birth--
well, they use
different methods.
But one as I recall
was looking to housing,
looking at housing
and residency.
And so I'm wondering
from Martha,
given the current climate
and the controversy
over the census, which is
a different way of counting
than birth registration,
if we should be looking to,
who's a resident?
Anybody who's a resident
of Massachusetts
is a citizen of Massachusetts.
Anyone born here is
a citizen of the US.
So what do you think
about residency?
Not just family ties,
anchor babies, whatever.
- Well, your question goes right
to the heart of the question,
doesn't it?
Which is to say perhaps
we could contrast
our case to myriad examples
in Europe about how European
nations grapple with the
status and the inevitability
of refugees, be they
economic, political,
or otherwise would be a
way to think about that.
Should we begin to distinguish
between residents and citizens
in ways?
The question of
how Massachusetts
deems a resident and the
United States deems a resident,
doesn't it feel like we're
on the cusp of that question
as both states and
municipalities begin
to invoke the asylum
principle for their territory?
So I think partly
we are there, right?
We are asking those questions.
And I'm happy to hear about the
conference that you attended.
I'm happy for this
conversation, because I
think it's time for us to have
that conversation in the open
and to be prepared for
the kinds of debates.
I think if once upon
a time, you know,
the asylum city,
the asylum state
was an aspirational
and a symbolic gesture.
Well, we're about to
see that tested, I
think, in legal ways that
will take us right back
to the 19th century for me and
debates about what it meant
when the state of
Massachusetts regarded
a former slave as a citizen
and the United States did not.
So thank you for that.
- Thank you.
Please.
- I'm Jody Lisberger.
I'm a professor of gender
and women's studies
from the University
of Rhode Island.
Tali, this is a
question for you.
I'm interested in the
studies that you're doing,
but I find the work so
gendered, reifying gender
in terms of how you're
very strongly delineating
men and women.
And I'm also thinking about
gender fluidity and the number
of people in our world who do
not identify strictly as male
or female or men as women.
You said in your comment
that norms, as a quote,
"determine who
will get respect."
What are you doing
to change the norms?
That is, you seem to put
the burden of responsibility
on women, what you
call women speaking up.
What about shifting
the norms so that men
who you identify as
men, and I think there
are people all
across the spectrums,
identifying those patterns of
behavior and changing them?
- Could I just--
are you done?
I'm sorry.
I don't want to--
what I wanted to do, I
think, just because-- so that
says four minutes, 17 seconds.
We maybe have a little
more time than that.
Could I take two
questions at once so
that we could get
more of you in?
Please.
- My name is Priscilla Douglas.
I used to teach at
Radcliffe seminars.
My area is leadership.
I'm wondering about the tone,
the mood of this country that
affects the conversation and the
policies that are being adapted
around race, immigration.
In my opinion, the tone and mood
around previous administrations
is significantly different from
the tone, the mood, the hatred
around what's happening today,
compounded by disinformation.
So what do you think about
the tone and the mood
and the influence on policy?
- Thanks.
That's a great question.
Who wants to start?
Kari, why don't you start?
- Sure.
On that tone, I think
that's the challenge
that the left needs to take on.
Martha, I loved your talk.
But if I can push back, why
not embrace family values?
And I say that
because if it was only
used in the context of gay
marriage to should just say--
as a nice way to
discriminate against people,
or why not put this
as a moral aspiration
that we all should have?
Because if we do start
talking about morality,
part of the morality--
I completely agree with you that
immigration is a family system.
And that whether it be the
mixed families or what have you,
and the court are recognizing
that the rights of immigrants
aren't foreigners and
strangers at the borders.
It's the rights to
citizens to have
these people as
part of our families
and part of our communities.
And so I completely
agree that I think
it's time for the left to take
a very forceful moral view,
and defend it and defend it well
to explain why we need a more
inclusive world and why we need
more immigrants in particular
to be a part of our community.
- Thank you.
Anyone else want to take on
any of the other questions?
Yeah?
- Yeah.
Thank you for that question.
On gender fluidity,
I agree absolutely
that it's vitally important
to theorize and empirically,
systematically investigate the
situation faced by gender fluid
people.
I don't agree that this study
reifies hard gender categories,
but rather, the attempt
is to understand how many,
many people who do
identify as cisgender
conduct themselves in
the halls of power.
And so I would say,
this is an initial step
to understand that category,
the cisgender category.
And I very much hope that
this theoretical framework
and this methodology of
systematically counting
each time someone is
interrupted, systematically
counting, how many times
does a person articulate
their unique perspective,
systematically measuring
all kinds of outcomes,
including the hard dollar
amounts that policy
sets, which influences
people's lives in
very concrete ways,
I would hope that people would
find some utility in that
as well, and expand it to
other kinds of identities.
How do we change the norms?
I certainly don't intend to
be putting the burden on women
or any other identity category
that is already disadvantaged.
To the contrary,
this is not Lean In.
[LAUGHTER]
This is, we need to
change the structure.
We need to change the rules.
We need to change institutions.
But we need to do
it in a smart way,
and recognize that
the numbers of women
present are going
to matter in how
the rules change gender dynamics
and narrow inequalities.
We need to think hard
about, is everyone present
really given free and
easy access to the floor?
We all need to
interrogate that, and we
need to do it through
changing these rules,
changing these structures.
And in addition, part
of what we've identified
is that a very
destructive mechanism that
makes all of this work is
men's verbal aggression
towards women.
And so in that
sense, this is a call
and an invitation to men in
general to be more self-aware.
So again, this is not,
women need to change things.
But rather, it is
a call for women
to realize that it is
possible to gain empowerment
by changing the rules.
- Thank you.
Now we are theoretically
at the end.
If each of you could ask
really really, really fast--
and I'll let Martha
sort of close,
because you were the one
person not in this last round.
So if you can be really quick,
I want to include both of you.
- Sure.
Good morning.
My name is Diane Felicio.
A quick follow-up
question for Tali.
Women leaders leading
women leaders.
I find myself in that
situation quite a bit.
Especially politically
curious if your research
can speak to that at all.
- And--
- She's got it.
She's ours.
- Oh, OK.
[LAUGH]
Perfect.
- I was going to
answer Tali's question.
[LAUGHTER]
- Tali, you want to
go quick on that?
I'll let Martha close, and then
I have one quick thing to say.
- Yes.
Thanks for that.
There is emerging
evidence that having
women in very visible and
concretely powerful positions
does have an influence
on recruiting more
women into positions of power.
If a cisgender woman
is governor of a state,
recent results suggest
that she does quite a bit
to promote the entry
of women into office.
And we also know that
voters, cisgender women
in the electorate, are
much more likely to gain
political knowledge and gain
political empowerment when
they see women in actual,
visible, concrete positions
of power.
- And finally, Martha.
- So if I could, I'll
just come back to briefly
Priscilla Douglas'
question about tone.
I appreciate it
very much, because I
think there's a way in
which we can come back
to values and morality and
this kind of discourse.
But it is also true that Jody's
question suggested to me--
many of us, I'll
say, I am learning
to do that with a new
kind of nuance, right?
Which is to say when I invoke
categories like gender,
like race, the meanings
and the nuances,
the subtleties, the textures of
those categories have shifted.
And I have to be mindful of
the transgendered members
of my community just
as I am aware of men
and women in my community, or
people who identify as such.
I find myself using Ta-Nehisi
Coates' somewhat awkward
phrasing, right?
People who believe
themselves to be white.
People who are believed to be
white rather than white people.
And this is a burden on us.
I think it's an
imperative on us to speak
through the sort of tone
that we would call for,
to insist on the kind
of nuance as well that I
think is missing from this
particular historical moment.
So thank you so much
for that question.
- Thank you.
I want to close with one
sentence and a quotation.
The one sentence is I'm
very grateful for what you
said just a moment ago, Kari.
Because for at
least three decades,
I have been obsessed
with a paradox
in our political
conversation that it's
the political right that talks
a lot about family values,
but feminists and
progressives who
talk the most about what
it takes to make families
and childrearing work better.
And somehow, we have to bring
those conversations together,
or challenge the prevailing--
what family values is
taken to mean and try to make
it mean something substantive.
The quotation I can't resist
ending this panel with
is from somebody
many of you know,
Rose Schneiderman, the famous
American trade unionist.
And it seemed appropriate for
an opening panel on citizenship.
"What the woman who
labors wants is the right
to live, not simply exist, the
right to life as the rich woman
has the right to life, and
the sun and music and art.
You have nothing that the
humblest worker has not
a right to have also.
The worker must have bread,
but she must have roses too.
Help, you women of privilege.
Give her the ballot
to fight with."
Thank you, Martha.
Thank you, Kari.
And thank you, Tali.
[APPLAUSE]